and thanks for the opportunity to be
here what I'd like to do in today's talk
we're going to cover a lot of turf and
I'm going to move really fast if you
want to stop and ask questions that's
fine we can spend the time however you
like and I'll try to do my best to
repeat the questions as they come for
those who are not physically here if I
forget please please flag me in all and
I'll try to make the questions clear so
the project that I'm going to talk about
the synchronized multi sensor integrated
learning environment is actually a
conglomeration of a number of activities
that we've had going on at CMU for the
last four or five years so I am at the
silicon valley campus which is located
in NASA Ames Research Park and we have
about 400 students more or less depends
on which semester you're talking about
and of course we have we don't have all
of CMU here in Silicon Valley we have a
thin slice and it's three departments
Electrical and Computer Engineering I'm
affiliated with them the information
networking Institute and the integrated
innovation Institute so ECE in Silicon
Valley is not all of ECE there we are a
slice of that our the expertise among
the faculty who are there or mostly in
the realm of Internet of Things wireless
wireless systems sensing privacy
security things that are generally
related to the Internet of Things as
well as software engineering obviously
relators and then in the other
departments product management software
management entrepreneurship so we have a
habit of creating bicoastal programs
where students really have the
experience to go back and forth between
the main campus and Silicon Valley and
that seems to be working pretty well so
what I want what I would like to do by
way of motivation is to give you some
observations that I've made that I think
may bear on this topic of how sensors
and the Internet of Things may come to
be I'm not I'll admit upfront I'm not an
adherent to what a lot of people talk
about for the Internet of Things my view
of what it's going to be is actually
rather different and there are some big
ugly problems that stand between us and
that vision of future which is for a
researcher and opportunity right so
wireless systems wireless technology
sort of generally and the ones that I'm
going to talk about today really offer
some great promise and so there's a lot
of talk about smart cities smart
manufacturing environments the smart
home and many of these things as is true
in early markets prefigure what will be
but really what we know now will be set
aside in favor of something else so I'm
interested in to something else and so
we're digging into what people are
viewing as the smart city doing
prototyping and building systems really
not in search of the answers but in
search of the questions of what will
stand between us and real smart and some
real smart kinds of environments the
interesting thing that kind of starts me
off is is economic if we actually
imagine a smart city it's likely that
the sensing and actuation that makes up
smart intersections responsive traffic
control systems safety systems whatever
are not going to be built by a single
organization at a single time out of a
single set of consistent components in
fact it will be the opposite of those
things it'll be a federation of
separately built dissimilar systems
owned and operated by separate people
who have separate privacy and
information ownership points of view and
in that be is really the heart of a
number of problems so there are some key
challenges that I can do that I am
concerned about and this is by no means
a comprehensive list but the earth were
merging the emerging Internet of Things
as I see it is is sort of it is is is a
problem domain that like many good
engineering domains has at its heart a
really interesting impossible problem I
think every good engineering domain has
at its heart so I'm impossible problem
and the impossible problem at the heart
of the Internet of Things is we're going
to see is power and energy and many of
the things that also are related trace
their roots back to power and energy so
the high-performance and computing and
communications in small devices is an
enabler for a lot of what we might be
thinking about doing today tiny form
factors will be sort of dearer I think
that a lot of the Internet of Things is
going to be what we call lick and stick
sensors very tiny to physically tiny
devices that they
or will be somewhat impoverished in
terms of energy but maybe not in terms
of computation so they but they do have
to run advantaging lilo vanishing low
power levels the ability to harvest
energy is somewhat limited we'll talk
about that and the onboard energy
sources are of course limited by limited
by physics so in addressing these
challenges we take on some new new new
risks and things that might not be
obvious from a technology perspective so
we did a little thought experiment with
our friends the city of Palo Alto and
elsewhere where we imagined a day in the
life of the city council or
representative from some large
three-letter company that I might have
worked for in my past
now now focused on services comes
knocking and says mr. city manager will
be happy to make Palo Alto smart I will
make it smarter if you'll only pay us 50
million dollars and take on this load of
software and sensors and so on and the
city manager puts his arm around the
fellow from the three hundred company
takes them over to the water cooler and
says let me explain something to you
last week here at City Council we
wrangled for six hours and we finally
made a decision to buy eight new stop
signs the week before that we had a
similar angle and we agreed to fill
thirty potholes at no point can I
imagine in the future that we are going
to give you no matter how smart you are
no matter how good you are no matter how
realistic your promises might be fifty
million dollars to make our city smart
okay so if you think that Palo Alto is
is an outlier and that of course it's
not true Palo Alto is probably the city
that a lot other cities look to for
guidance in terms of in terms of what
they do so that's a real that's kind of
a chilling that's kind of a chilling
vision for those of us who like to play
in this world of cyber physical systems
cyber-physical in the sense that we'd
like to scrape information out of the
physical world turn it into a problem
that we can compute with and somehow
create value out of that
but the problem is that cities as the
recipient of this stuff have
personalities and those personalities
will actually get in the way of
realizing the Smart City vision right so
the ADAAA the adoption of these new
ideas is typically slow really
can we even think about making city
smart using a top-down approach where
you go to the city of Palo Alto and
offer 50 million dollars I argue that
that's not where we're at today and
really we should be looking more at
enabling bottoms-up opportunities to
exploit sensors and computation cyber
physicality if you will and cities so
how is that going to come about and who
and who would care about it who would
who would help make it make it fly so
we'll talk a little bit about those
things so some implicit criteria for
success if we're actually going to do
this is we have to have to please our
city managers we can't tell them well we
have to build a custom device for this
application a custom device for that one
and tailor this and send in an army of
service representatives to know the the
idea of smart cities I think it's much
more like integrating whatever it is
that we do with the people who make say
stop signs because cities already know
how to buy stop signs we said that right
and they know how to install stop stop
signs and then when the lifecycle of a
stop sign is so we have to figure out
that if we're going to make a city smart
any infrastructure elements that we
would introduce to the city had probably
better look feel and smell like the
infrastructure elements that the city
already knows how to deal with okay one
of the popular examples that I like and
we kind of followed this one is the bots
dot how many people know what a BOTS dot
is well that's good in California that
the more hands than not because Botts
dots were invented by BOTS at the
California Department of Transportation
had spots dot they were these little
ceramic domes that you can still see on
the pavement surface today and they're
there specifically because of
weather-related problems in California
when it rains you can't see the lines so
bot said I could solve that by putting
these little ceramic domes well since
that it's evolved to something called a
Stimson height marker that has
reflectors in it and so on
but that's something that a city already
knows how to install right pick your
favorite city there's probably a name
Joe or Steve or Dan or Lyle who can do
lick and stick sensing right he has a
bag full of sensors and he knows how to
take them out and stick them on the road
what if we could put intelligence in
those dots and make them have the same
lifetime as the dots themselves that
sort of offers hope but we
that comes of course the constraints of
the small size of the device and what
you could cram into it in terms of
electronics and particularly battery
okay so city for any friendly
integration typically means introducing
technology that's invisible to the Joe
or the Frank or the Fred of the Lyle or
whatever who actually has to install
this stuff in the city okay and now the
other problem is this we've been
studying distributed computing for how
many years now years 50 years this is
the world's largest ugliest hairiest
distributed computing problem because
the the numbers are staggering right
you're going to be programming a hundred
thousand devices in a typical smart city
maybe a million devices in a typical
smart they're going to be dissimilar as
we said and federated many will fail
right so we have all the fault tolerance
issues to deal with we have the physical
distribution we have latency we have
network communication we have
synchronization which we will come back
to and if we really want to make city
smart my hypothesis is we have to make
programming a city no more difficult
than writing an Android or an iOS app
wouldn't it be amazing if we could
create somehow the tools that would let
the same three million people or
whatever the number is who made smart
phones what they are today by writing
apps using their time energy and effort
if we could somehow give them the same
facilitation of a software development
kit and a reliable pile of hardware if
you will that's no more difficult well
so that's it that's a big leap right
typical smartphone you're programming
the phone itself maybe there's some
cloud service behind it but now we're
talking about coordinating hundreds of
thousand devices so we have quite a long
way to go before we have before we have
a mechanism for for doing that so these
will these these problems which
which are sort of immediately apparent
when you think about deployment lead to
some interesting technological
challenges and I referred to the power1
let's let's take a look at some of these
problems in a little more detail as
motivations for this project that we
call smile so the first problem here's a
test the first problem is called the
Ohio problem anybody know what the Ohio
problem is has nothing to do with John
Glenn's birth state yeah it means I only
handle it once right and the idea is
this if we're to actually make devices
in the internet of things come on if
we're actually if we're actually true to
this idea of making devices in the
internet of things truly have a low cost
of ownership not a low cost of
manufacture we have to understand that
going out and servicing these million
devices replacing the battery injecting
new software reorienting them so they're
antennas point towards some gateway is
simply impractical because the economics
of doing that far outweigh the cost of
the device okay so now we truly have the
problem of sensors or whatever the
devices are that we hypothesize putting
in the smart city as being like a stick
okay so we can ill afford to send
somebody out to adjust all of those
devices so this has some interesting
quarters if we actually believe that
okay if the economics of deployment and
maintenance so we'll wipe out the
possibility of deployment we're stuck
with this problem what does it mean well
first of all it means that unlike
writing software for some large social
media or a search engine company where
you can literally change the software
overnight and just with a knob say which
percentage of my population is going to
be on version 1 versus version 2 we
really have to think more in terms of
writing software and designing hardware
for a mission to Mars where once off the
launch pad there's not a lot that we can
do to go change our minds about what it
is so that's a fundamental difference in
the way we have to think about designing
these things the second is related to
that we have to pack our all the
sandwiches that we need for the mission
because there's no there's no subway
along the way where we can go get some
more energy
and and and the point that I made
earlier about energy harvesting I think
if you do the math you find that energy
harvesting may actually be good for
extending life time but it's not
something on which we can fundamentally
base a deployment of sensors that could
go anywhere in a city under shade under
bridges whatever okay so pack your
energy the third is we have to think
really hard about where we put the
computation so the world of wireless
sensor networks over the last twenty
years largely approach the problem of
sense compute actuate by vesting very
comparatively little software in the
devices that do the sensing themselves
instead we have devices that sit on the
wall that say over the network it's 72
degrees it's 72 degrees it's 72 degrees
it's 72 degrees and something on the
other end of the connection looks for
changes okay it's generally a if your
network is wired you have and you have
enough enough capacity to waste on some
server to listen to this this mindless
prattle that's fine
but if you're a wireless device and you
have to put energy into every bit that
you push over a noisy channel all of a
sudden you start asking the question do
I really want to do that do I really
want to stream the values from the
transducers to the cloud where I have
infinite computing and infinite and so
on well the problem is you don't have
infinite energy to invest in pushing
those bits over that noisy Channel okay
so where do we draw the line yes sir
yes I will try but I will I will so
where do we draw the line how do we
think about where do we draw the line
well the way that I think about it just
from a very simple-minded perspective is
the stuff out of women which we make
this Internet of Things stuff our
systems on chip inexpensive increasingly
dense devices that we can that we can
fill up with software that could do some
sort of processing and do the data
communication as well well but those two
things are actually quite different from
an energy management perspective if we
imagine the evolution of these
systems on chip overtime okay is the
technology for the SOC s gets better and
better what's gonna happen to how much
computing we can put on the device
versus how much communication we can do
well you can believe what you might
about Moore's law but at the bottom
where we have these little Internet of
Things devices there's actually quite a
lot of room to continue to improve them
so that the same computation that you
run today on your little IOT device
being an FFT or removing average filters
or what-have-you
is going to cost less in next year's
chip in terms of energy to run it than
it does today it's actually a reasonably
good bet as time goes on the cost of
doing local computation is going to
decline what about the cost of
communication well if we believe that we
have code we know how to code
information then send it over noisy
channels we can't push beyond the
Shannon limit ok so there's actually a
hard physical limit that says you're
never gonna get you're never gonna be
able to code better so that you can push
more bits from the device to the cloud
you'll hit you'll hit you'll hit a floor
now those lines those curves cross and
it says something actually quite
interesting that for some applications
say today doing the computation remotely
might result in less and less power used
on the device because you're you're
doing something that would require you
know it's more complex computation than
you can afford it's cheaper to send the
bits over-the-air in an energy sense
than it is to compute them locally but
as the devices get better the trend is
clearly in the direction of doing the
computing on the device so we now have
the V and energy economics voting in
favor of more distribution of function
which means more programming complexity
but the benefit that we get from it is a
longer-lasting battery or more complex
computation that we can do in this
sensor network so that's kind of
interesting
so the energy concerns push us toward
local local sensing just to put some
numbers on it if we look at us at what
is today a typical IOT device and the
battery that might power it say a
thousand milliamp hour lithium vinyl
chloride battery and we ask the question
if we want a device that's powered by
such a battery to last for five years
and we make some simple
about the battery self-discharge and so
on how much energy can we put into each
of these basic operations each hour
computing
transmitting receiving well it's not
pretty
so sensing and processing in today's
math you get about 30 seconds worth of
that or non-modern SOC and 5 seconds
worth of receiving and transmitting and
next year you might be able to get a
little more sensing and processing but
but the receiving and transmitting as we
said are not going to get a whole lot
better so and and most of the time of
course during that hour in the life is
the device is totally asleep this says a
couple of things one as we said before
we don't want to we we really have to
think very differently about this kind
of computing it's it's asleep rather
than awake and the second is that we
don't want to waste transmit receive
power on network protocol overhead or
anything else that's non-productive
which and so we call this the power
challenge and that's the big deep ugly
nasty thing that based on the IOT
paramus umph shion's of how will deploy
really really pushes us the second
factor the thing second thing that we
have to consider is time synchronization
among these devices if we want to be
able to synchronize sensing in an
environment we have to have some basis
for deciding when when two or more
sensors in an environment sense some
quantity and we want to correlate those
in the cloud we have to have a basis for
deciding that the values that they've
reported with time stamps on them can in
fact be correlated well is that a
reasonable assumption turns out that
just running a clock at reasonably high
precision consumes a significant amount
of power so now we have to concern
ourselves with the trade-off between
what timing accuracy does the
application require and how much of the
battery power are we going to are we
going to put into maintaining an
accurate clock okay we'll come back to
that so different applications of course
have different levels of synchronization
requirements we did a project for the US
Geological Survey where we built some
software for smartphones or at least
demonstrated the principles for doing
that that would allow us to do early
earthquake warning the idea is this no
it's not detecting using accelerometers
shaking what we're looking for is
correlated ground movement across a
number of phones in a geographic area
right people who worry about earthquakes
sensing this is interesting people who
worry about earthquake sensing think in
terms of timescales from 1 to 100
seconds with physical displacements on
with the order of 1 to 100 centimeters
okay so really looking for route 880
going like this so we'd like to know of
the phones that are on route 80 80 are
they moving in a direction that doesn't
align with the directions of travel the
road okay well it turns out that that
kind of correlation with the time scales
that we care about don't require tight
synchronization among the phones right
that's kind of a good one well as you
move down the scale to what else you
might want to want a sense correlating
say video frames from multiple cameras
in a security setting or from drones or
whatever now you'd like frame accurate
synchronization so now you're down in
the realm of mic 10 milliseconds or so
more interestingly if you want to do
something like taking simple sensors and
using them to do acoustic detection
where I try to determine which direction
Andy is using not my eyes but my ears I
need in order to do the the angle of
arrival computation toward Andy I need
to be able to sample and correlate those
audio samples down to about 5
microseconds all right
cheap device that can do audio detection
and and and returning values and
waveforms to me but I have to put a lot
of power into the clock to make it run
well enough synchronized so that you
know a 20 microsecond error is gonna
mean that I'm thinking Andy's over here
instead of thinking he's over there so
the application determines how much
power we have to put into the clock okay
that's the time challenge the third
thing is as we said before these these
sensors are not going to be built by
some monolithic installation strategy
it's going to be many sensor systems
that will be integrated after the fact
and we have to there's there's a lot to
be said about that
and I'm gonna have to skip some of that
for the sake of time today now here's
the programming problem
if we think about programming a network
of Internet of Things sensors obviously
we have to do the embedded programming
for the device ok that's clear
and we probably have to do some cloud
computing to aggregate that data put the
data in a database build some nice
visualization tools or whatever and all
along the way we've got this we've got
billions and billions of dollars worth
of networking equipment cellular or
whatever they really don't contribute to
the problem of doing the computation
well that's that's a sad fact it may be
changing as educating becomes a thing
over the next 10 years so we have we
have at the bottom of this pyramid
smartphones and fitbit's and things like
that that are embedded that are
programmed in an embedded sense but now
we have to correlate that program with
whatever whatever goes on in the cloud I
can attest that for firsthand experience
doing that and keeping the code bases
and the header files and all of that
stuff synchronizes a hard enough problem
but doing anything more intelligent like
figuring out having these devices
self-described their position and having
the cloud software respond accordingly
is actually a pretty hard problem and
it's a lot to put on it's a lot to put
on programmers so what would be great
and what we don't have today is a
mechanism for expressing say an
application for a smart intersection
that will correlate information from
pavement sensors and stoplights and
cameras and the Tesla's and Priuses that
go whizzing through the intersection and
somehow deduce from all of that
information that a collision is imminent
but we don't have that this I believe is
the is the linchpin to doing what what
Apple and Google did for the app model
we need some way of letting programmers
write one program that somehow gets
decomposed into bits that run on the
cloud on the device and possibly in the
network that can be that their their
correlation their testing as a unit can
be thought of as more of a single system
so we don't have that that's the
programming challenge so the if we think
of those four challenges that I've
talked about they're actually pretty
well interrelated I think we've already
talked about how programming and power
programming time and power
programming and Federation all have a
connection with one another so really we
cannot address the problem of how to
build the architecture for the Internet
of Things by looking just at devices or
just at time synchronization or just at
information sharing and in XML
dictionaries with matched keys that let
us correlate temperature information
from two different sensors that were
made by two different manufacturers it's
really a system problem and and getting
it right
requires sort of a combined effort of
recognizing problems attacking them
building prototypes deploying them and
then figuring out what question we
really should have asked and then doing
the lather rinse repeat kind of cycle so
these we really have a platform kind of
challenge now sorry thank you Andy
alluded to the fact that in my dark past
I had some relationship with that with
companies that made big computers right
I worked for IBM for 14 and a half years
and it scares my students to death when
I tell them that they can go down to the
Computer History Museum and see an IBM
mainframe that these two hands built the
earth motika qunit for but you know
maybe not enough great here I don't know
what it is but they but but it's true I
did I did work on on big big iron in the
past so I'm going to tell you a little
story and a conclusion I'll start with
the conclusion then I'll give you the
story that comes from having lived
through several eras of platform
computing and I think it has something
to say about how we build the platform
for the Internet of Things ok we're
gonna start off with
Iannucci slaw humbly named after your
speaker and AIA new cheese law says that
in each generation of computing the
emergence of a standard platform
transforms the industry by shifting
value read money from hardware to
software to services ok and I see some
heads shaking ok and some skeptical
faces maybe in the audience who haven't
lived through this so let's let's
actually go through this and yes sir
which is yes that's true
good good so let's engage what I would I
call some market texture thinking and
and look at the look at the market
architecture and see what it can predict
about the future okay so here we have
four generations of computing mainframe
mini PC and mobile and I worked at IBM
in the mainframe era and I worked at Dec
and Compaq in the mini era and I worked
for IBM although you know it was still
sort of a mainframe company I was
fighting with the senior management to
get them to embrace this idea of
personal computers
I heard learned that Dennis was the tiny
basic guy that's that's very cool
so I was I was alive and kicking her in
that area and then of course I was at
Nokia during during its heyday in the
mobile era okay so I sort of have seen
this movie and there's a pattern and
when I share the pattern with you so in
the early days of mainframes there was
the bunch everybody remember the bunch
Burroughs universe UNIVAC NCR CDC
Honeywell bunch right and in those days
this is in the 50s computing was a
priesthood and we know that computing
was a priesthood because of the language
that we use when we talk about running a
program on a computer what did we do we
submitted our patch job right literally
we took our took our deck of cards and
brought it to the priests who were on a
raised floor and we and we submitted our
job okay in those days the value was
clearly in the hardware the hardware was
dissimilar and then an amazing thing
happened in 1964 IBM said you know it
might actually be a good idea this is
the 704 and the 1790 and the 1401
IBM had these glorious wonderful
machines but they had a problem
customers who had a 1401 who wanted to
upgrade faced the problem of having to
rewrite their software and this slowed
down sales so the IBM geniuses in those
days said wouldn't it be cool if we can
have sort of a line of computers that
all run the same software they were
thinking instruction set and we could
just let the let customers buy up
right we would build a scalable range of
machines that would that would address
this that would be programmed using this
instruction set and over its history
I've kind of lost track of it now the
IBM 360 the IBM 360 not only was the the
basis for IBM taking being taken to task
by the Justice Department for potential
monopolistic practices because we had
70% of the market but it technologically
it engendered a series of machines that
spanned a performance range of more than
a hundred to one probably approaching a
thousand to one so that's like 30 DB
dynamic scaling that's not bad for a
platform architecture to live and to and
to span that kind of that kind of range
okay so by making the hardware standard
IBM did two things they took the
discussion of I can't upgrade because I
have to rewrite off the table which was
good for IBM economically but what else
did it do with this commonality comes
commoditization when you say all
machines are created equal all of a
sudden the differentiation kind of
vanishes and it becomes a race to the
bottom right so what happened then
well gene Amdahl went off and did his
own thing and Magnuson was formed which
I think was genes son if I'm not
mistaken
plus the Fujitsu guys went off and they
all said ah okay iBM is is gonna
dominate the world with this 360
instruction set we'll just copy it and
we'll make machines that do the same
thing and we'll sell it for 20% less or
what have you
well that's kind of interesting and so
the laws of economics took over and all
of a sudden people were talking about
not the hardware but the next harder
problem which was building the software
and CSC probably the young faces in this
room there are too many never heard of
CSC okay billion-dollar software company
that came came to glory in the 1960s
when the value sort of shifted from the
hardware toward the software yeah and
then toward the end of that era the CIO
said you know I don't want to deal with
with with CSC to on software and and all
and the leasing companies which IBM
hated the leasing companies would buy
equipment and lease it which took the
wind out of IBM's sails so IBM found
itself competing on a hardware basis
didn't like that but the CIOs didn't
like it either because now they had all
these Hardware choices it used to be
that you know no one ever got fired for
by buying IBM they would just buy the
IBM mainframe they would get IBM to
consult on the software when this world
changed out from underneath them they
didn't want to do that so they said you
know maybe we'd want to do is we just
want to buy a service and through that
service somebody else will figure out
what machine and what software and we'll
just you know let them we'll buy a
payroll service okay so again IBM came
around and said you know services that's
you know that's actually a good business
maybe we should be moving away from the
big blue boxes because the value in the
market has shifted okay so that's end of
movie trailers role you know post
trailer scene and all the stuff that we
expect many computer era comes around
the Massachusetts miracle right prime
Apollo Wang computers remember Wang word
processors DAC data general and it
wasn't exactly the same thing but it was
pretty close when the world's when the
when the when Ken Olsen said let there
be VAX and what happened with VAX and of
course the contributions of the of the
UNIX community we now had what looked
like a platform computer it could be it
you could get big ones and little ones
you could not worry so much about the
hardware but what it did do not so much
in cloning the computers it generated a
huge market in in in in hardware for all
the discs and peripherals that plugged
into the backs mainframe remember Emulex
right so they made a lot of money in
that marketplace so the value then
started to shift from hardware to
software and of course Oracle decided
well we'll have a database will run on
every machine on the face of the planet
so that the people who want to run a
database don't have to think about the
hardware and then ETS stepped in and
said to the CIOs we'll manage this whole
thing for you all right not to believe
or the point PC era was a golden age of
hardware IBM said let there be PC
consolidation of the industry compact
became a billion-dollar company faster
than any other
company in history doing exactly what
the last two runs of the movie said that
they should do which was take the
offered platform standard and make it
cheaper Microsoft of course made its
fortune realizing that the next step in
the in this era was the value shifting
towards software and what happened at
the end of era IBM came back and said
we'll do the services I was at Nokia in
the days when IBM we had IBM in in Nokia
for two reasons one we had 50,000 IBM
laptops write to IBM ran our computing
infrastructure and I asked people which
do you think Nokia would rather give up
would Nokia rather give up the 10,000
pcs and buy them from Dell or whatever
would they rather have IBM replaced in
running the payroll in the manufacturing
facilities and it was a horrific thought
right clearly the PCs were not valuable
at all what was valuable were the
services that IBM had gotten itself
deeply wedded to inside Nokia and in
many other companies so pattern golden
age standard platform value decline in
hardware shift to value and software
shift to value and services and content
thank you very much so how about mobile
well the the standard platform for
mobile actually a little bit of a
different beast right the standard
platform for mobile is not an
instruction set it's an ecosystem right
you've got the Android ecosystem
you've got the iOS ecosystem and
particularly in the Android ecosystem
we've seen a decline in the value that's
associated with a hardware because it's
a competitive marketplace right standing
so the question that is if we've seen
this movie three and a half times and we
know how it ends each time what does it
tell us about the Internet of Things
what do you think
yeah so the first thing that I say is
well for the Internet of Things we had
better expect that there's going to be
this golden age of incompatible hardware
that we will largely throw out because
it will be wrong and that's where we're
at today then the next step if you're a
betting person is to figure out what
would bring about a standard platform
for the Internet of Things this is where
a large sum of money is to be made okay
so my hypothesis not as a business
person but as a market echt an arm-chair
market tech is that the next thing is
going to be this hype this cyber
physical network and what is a cyber
physical network okay it's an
integration of two things flexible
powerful programmable devices open
device families and flexible powerful
programmable open wired and wireless
networks designed for the next hundred
billion devices and guess what
first one mostly exists second one
doesn't exist at all it ain't the
cellular network and for good reason
okay so will is it you know if that's
true is it going to emerge simply
through an evolution of existing
wireless networks I think the answer to
that is also no okay well let's talk a
little bit more about what what what the
attributes of this solution will if
we're to find a solution what will its
attributes be first of all it's got to
face the fact that this world is
distributed federated and energy poor
and we have to be able to program it in
some sort of a way that finally lets us
separate answering questions of
correctness is the algorithm that I've
written for crash detection logically
correct separate from the problem of
where do I put the pieces of the problem
where do I put the sensors the computing
the data storage okay we should be able
to do that and there's been research
projects in the past who have tried that
have tried to do that but now we have to
do it for real and we have to do it in a
large scale otherwise and and I'm making
a strong statement if we do not do this
the vision of the Internet of Things
transforming our lives smart cities and
all that is literally out the window
okay so this is not just a wish this is
a this is where I'm tying a future value
to the
faction of this requirement the radio
access network I'm numb now I've moved
from being an architect to being a
cellular and wireless kind of guy so I
talk in acronyms that are maybe a little
different than the architects in the
audience would recognize ran radio
access network is the thing that goes
between the cellular tower in your phone
okay obviously an area of very hot
research it turns out that or my belief
is that for this vision to be realized
what we've learned from the cellular
companies that there will be one radio
to rule them all ofd M OFDM a LTE five g
5g standalone non standalone mumble fou
3gpp is the only way to approach the
radio problem that is not true and we'll
explain why that is not sure why that
should not be true okay and in fact we
should make just like we made hardware
instruction set architectures a
non-issue by standardizing cont
compilers moving the the argument up the
same I believe is going to be true for
radio access networks the exclusivity
that's associated with OFDM OFDM a LTE
all those acronyms in the world of the
IOT will give way to what will
eventually be called multi radio true
multi radio networks multi radio multi
protocol and there are good energy based
reasons for claiming that this is so ok
so the network that we hope for is not
your parents cellular network which in
my view is almost but not quite entirely
unlike a real IP network ok we continue
to benefit from the idea that
transistors and the devices are free and
at the low end in the world of the
internet of things we can bet on that
for a long time time is has to be a
first-order concept in programming
imagine a programming language where
time really is a first-order concept as
opposed to a bolt on and edge computing
and all that we're talking about today
if for edge computing is going to vanish
in favor of something that we call
edgeless computing
I don't think networks should have edges
I think it's it's much more reasonable
to think about single coherent
programming environments that tie
together the devices the the computing
that we might do in the network in the
cloud but that's the topic for another
discussion for another day ok so that's
my that's the
right and now what are we doing about it
so in my group were taking not
surprisingly a systems approach to next
generation wireless networks and the
applications and the programming
environments and the core technologies
that make up what might be this cyber
physical Network of the future so we're
engaged in developing a range of sensors
some tools for doing low-power
programming I'm going to talk a little
bit about that some real deployments of
sensors on road surfaces applying
machine learning both at the cloud and
in sensor devices themselves but think
about that for a minute where we're
going with with with neural networks is
figuring out how to make them much more
efficient I say we the community by
making them much more efficient and and
very quickly we're seeing an overlap
between what's possible for computing on
a cortex m3 or some small small device
that you might put in the environment
and what's required with a say a
convolutional neural network there are
some neural networks that actually fit
and over time there's going to be
acceleration and support for neural
networks in sensing applications why
because of exactly we talked about
before it's cheaper with the with free
transistors it will be cheaper to do
local computation in a device than to
try to push bits over a noisy Channel
okay so neural networks are coming to it
to a dirt-cheap sensor near you and
we're we're exploring that as well we're
also doing some field prototyping we
have a pretty unique environment for
doing field based research we have an
old ambulance that we've turned into an
LTE network that's all you bought that
at the very end of the talk ok so here
are a few of the projects that we've got
going on in my group addressing a number
of problems so we're looking at
low-power synchronization in computing
integrating machine learning into
sensing federating machine learning
across dissimilar sensor types a new
project that we just were we just
started fairly recently under NSF
sponsorship which is the creation of a
language framework that's that seeks the
to solve the problems that we've talked
about before and some applications so
I'll go through those in turn
through them fairly quickly so that we
have some time for questions okay so the
first the first project called long shot
long range synchronization of time
question is if you're familiar with
low-power wide area networks these are
networks that can transmit on the order
of a thousand to ten thousand bits per
second using modulation techniques that
are robust and resilient against channel
noise samtech has popularized a scheme
called Laura that uses chirp spread
spectrum modulation works pretty well
and it's it's
now available very inexpensively from
multiple semiconductor vendors and it's
being used as the basis for sensor
networks around the world the question
is since then it's been highly optimized
for low power op or operate low-power
mostly off operation the question is can
we use that as a tool to implement time
synchronization in a way that costs
asymptotically zero additional power
okay because the classic way of sending
packets back and forth over a wireless
network ntp has its limitations so we
start with that idea and we developed
forward from that so we're looking at a
way to achieve microsecond level or tens
of microseconds level synchronization
and essentially no energy cost which
would enable devices to be to achieve
tight synchronization when they need it
but not maintained not run a clock at
high synchronization at high power
levels to maintain precise
synchronization over fluctuations in
temperature during off cycles and so on
okay important problem so here's what we
did we started with a classic algorithm
for doing time for synchronization over
networks the network time protocol ntp
and those of you who know the algorithm
will be bored to tears but the the basic
idea is actually quite simple if we have
two clocks in two devices the end device
and a gateway and our objective is to
synchronize the end devices clock to the
gateways clock and we have a network
that connects us what we do is we make
four simple measurements and a copy then
we do a computation we send a packet
from our end device to the Gateway and
when we send it we record our local time
based on our local / presumed incorrect
clock
call that t0 when the packet arrives at
the remote gateway at the instant that
the Gateway receives it records the time
of arrival based on its clock and then
it might do some processing in the in
the before it sends a reply packet but
it were sends a reply packet and in the
reply packet just as it's going out the
door it stamps the packet with the time
that the then-current time at the
network server and when we get it here
on the on the on the remote device we
record the time according to our local
imprecise clock and with a little bit of
math we can compute the we can compute
the offset between these two clocks by
estimating the network delay right we
know how long in our clock it took
between when we started and when we
finished that's the round-trip time and
we know if the server sends us t1 and t2
in that packet that it replies with we
can figure out how much time the server
sat doing nothing that's the network
server time if we subtract those two the
difference is the transit time okay now
we make a big assumption we assume the
transit time is symmetric and we divide
by 2 right
and having divided by 2 we can then take
the time t2 that we got in the packet
from the server we can subtract the one
way the divided by 2 round-trip time and
we now know that when our clock said t3
we can figure out what the service clock
was we can set our clock accordingly and
in principle this works really well in
practice you know what Einstein said
about the difference between theory and
practice that in theory there's no
difference between theory and practice
but in practice there is it's an in
practice when we run NTP we run into all
kinds of problems right in a you know an
IP network these links are rarely
symmetric and we rarely can figure out
what they are ok we can do lots of
trials and we can do statistical
aggregation and if we do it fast enough
we can make some assumption about what
the error must be given the rate at
which we sample and the rate at which
the network routes change and so on ok
now let's take that same idea in a
- this el cheapo signalling network
called Laura we'd like to do exactly the
same thing right we'd like to take send
a packet to the server have the server
respond and then do the computation well
what do we have to deal with if we do
that math it turns out that we're
running very slowly right we're not
sending a packet every millisecond we
may send a packet over the span of
seconds right if we send to spot two
packets they're gonna be seconds apart
during that span of time we have to deal
with the fact that this dirt-cheap clock
in our 50 cent sensor that has a three
cent resonator instead of a decent
crystal oscillator will have drifted
okay
NTP algorithm doesn't account for the
fact that the local clocks or the remote
clocks will drift the second thing that
we have to compare that we have to
concern ourselves with is these these
delays are actually a function of
physical distance right so we have to
find a way to solve for the distance the
network play and for the drift okay well
I won't belabor it if you if you
actually dig into it which we did every
single operation that the chip does and
sending a packet marking it as as having
been sent has to be has to be a
reverse-engineered so we very click
carefully looked at what information do
we get from the chip when it transmits
how can we deduce when the packet the
tail-end of the packet has in fact left
our server right when Elvis has left the
building here at t0 and when did it get
to the server and how do we know so this
is this is a you know some good hardcore
lab work which we did and it turns out
that the data sheets don't tell us
exactly what we need to know but with
the chips as they exist today they're
pretty deterministic thank God for state
machines okay so it turns out that if
you look for instance at the power
amplifier output on the transmitter you
might see something like this but the
report that the transmit signal is in
fact done comes significantly later okay
if you look at if you probe the power as
a proxy for when the when the actual
transmitter is turned off you see yet a
different story but it's all very
deterministic so with a little bit of
work we can figure out what the time is
between when we are told that the
transmission is complete and when the
transmission was actually
okay and with with a fair amount of work
we can do the same sort of thing on the
receive side right here's the here's the
incoming signal there's the there's the
interrupts that says yeah we've got the
packet but that's not what we want what
we really want is the event that
happened back here when we finished
receiving the packet okay well we can
back that out too
all right and so with some with some
good lab work and a little bit of math
we can actually do this and it turns out
that if we if we study it across some
different distances and across
temperature ranges and so on we can do
pretty darn well and in fact we're
getting results there so if you look at
the bandwidth of the signal which is a
proxy for how accurately you can use the
signal as a as a signal for time about
10 microseconds the ten microts isn't
about as good as you can get with a 125
kilohertz wide signal and we are you
know the air the air is very but we're
very close we're very close to the to
the theoretical limit and we're doing it
with just two packets and in fact we can
piggyback this time probing on regular
traffic right so we essentially get my
accuracy down to about 10 microseconds
synchronization for cheap devices using
essentially no additional power from the
battery okay works great now what does
this say so that works great for this
chip under the circumstances that we
simulated it what is the lesson that we
really learn from our research
perspective it teaches us that for the
chip manufacturers they're actually
exquisitely close to exposing this as a
function that's tremendously valuable
that costs almost nothing and if they
either publish the delay the live life
figures that that we had to go reverse
engineer or better yet they put the
clock in the chip and do the time
stamping in the chip then we get all
that benefit for essentially nothing you
might be familiar with the precision
time protocol I Triple E 1588 we
borrowed some ideas from 1588 to do this
but it works okay and it costs
essentially nothing it gets us closer to
the goal of precise synchronization in
though in this distributed world of the
Internet of Things where energy is so
precious
okay we've also built some tools
one of the things that our campus is
known for is software engineering we
turn out a phenomenal number of really
high quality software engineering grads
every year and guess where they go they
go to the G company in the F company in
the hell company where you know you
asked them about the economics of the
program that they wrote and they sort of
scratch their head what do you mean the
economics well how much power does it
take to run your program no yeah how
much so if you if you then take those
same students you plunk them down in
embedded systems course where all of the
resources have constraints right memory
is limited computing capacity is limited
and most importantly power is limited
what do they do right they don't know
from first principles what to do and
exactly right they have they have short
necks and flat foreheads because you ask
them question they go like this you tell
them the answer and they go like that so
what we can do what we have done is to
provide tools to let the power be made
manifest okay this is not something you
can do easily with an oscilloscope so we
did was we built a we built an
instrumentation system actually we built
a device that's a proxy for a whole host
of sort of low end SOC based Internet of
Things sensors not in form factor but in
terms of the processor this uses an arm
cortex-m 3 which is not a slouchy
processor but it's not 8-bit either it's
a real honest-to-goodness 32-bit
processor and by the way did I say
imagine that in this future world where
we have sensors being shared widely the
in the smart city every sensor is going
to be shared by multiple different
applications Reed multi-tenant Reed it's
probably going to be running Linux and
it will probably have different security
partitions and so on so we will have
data centers in these little devices
that sit on the pavement for
information-sharing reasons if nothing
else
so we built a device that's a proxy for
that it runs free our toss which is a
nice el cheapo but but good real-time
operating system that supports cues and
semaphores and in process scheduling
it's a pre-emptive multitasking
operating system so we built that device
and we put a bunch of sensors on it I
mean it's the form factor of this phone
actually surprisingly
not surprising that looks like an iPhone
six which is when we developed it it has
a camera it's got bluetooth it's got
Wi-Fi it actually has a slot which we've
now put a Laura radio onto so this have
actually a great device for prototyping
Internet of Things sensors and we teach
three classes at CMU they use this
prototyping device to teach the
principal the theme but the punchline is
this we've designed the power subsystem
for power due way such that the
processor the sensors the actuators and
the radios are on four separate power
domains and each one has a power meter
and on the backside of the board is
another processor that does nothing more
than read those power meters
synchronously and report them to a tool
that we've created you can't see it
terribly well on the screen here it's
essentially a four channel oscilloscope
that is showing the power per channel
but it's not just per channel we
actually have the the operating system
for your toss and the frontside
processor where your code goes in
cahoots with the instrumentation
processor so that every time a task
switch occurs it's whispered to the
instrumentation processor so now the
instrumentation processor can it can not
only tell you what the processor power
is it can say here's task sevens power
and here's task threes power and an
amazing thing happens when you put this
in front of students amazing thing power
optimization by three orders of
magnitude almost overnight really it's
amazing when you show students this they
say that test shouldn't be oh it's doing
a busy week yeah I can fix that
and all of a sudden board we have
low-power software and very successful
yes question well we so we could we
could very easily do a new version of
this with zinc on it well the one thing
that I really would like and I don't
know if maybe you can tell me as far as
I know the first versions of zinc and
and the board the the dev board that it
came with that exactly one sense
resistor for the whole processor and
what I want is the ability to monitor
the FPGA fabric or chunks of the FPGA
fabric separately so that I can put you
know
different clunks of logic in different
parts of the fabric and monitor the
power so if I mean we can talk about
that but yeah yeah I mean there's
there's a whole there's a whole host of
well given this I put this up in front
of people and say oh wow yeah that's yes
yes a tool for low power software
engineering makes sense so we built this
three four years ago and we now use it
pretty consistently in class in it and
it has the intended effect which is
which is helping helping us write
low-power software I want to switch
gears I just really quickly hit a couple
of other projects that are in this smile
domain and then tell you a little bit
about our kind of unique research
environment that we have at CMU sv so we
also are actually very interested in
multi-sensory learning meaning that we
have many sensors in the environment and
they can train one another okay so we
actually did a project where we have I'm
going to skip pretty quickly through
this where we have where we ask the
question first question is if we put
sensors if we want to put machine
learning in a sensor device how do we
train it online with minimal human
intervention this was motivated actually
by a problem of having a drone track
Andy when it isn't trained a priori to
recognize Andy when it takes off so we
started with we started with a basic
image recognition fabric and then built
and built a system that let us do
real-time learning and classification
with a ground operator that would get
Andy in view and then click on Andy's
image and then we did an interesting
thing we realized that if you have a
drone that can move and it moves even if
you don't want it to and Andy's gonna
move around the the the training events
the real-time clicking on Andy's are
expensive right if we have a soldier in
the field or an emergency services
worker who's looking to track somebody
or whatever having that person
repeatedly click click click every time
he sees Andy in the image and then
eventually the drone says oh ok yeah now
I know how to recognize Andy and when he
will get them but it took 57 training
events 57 clicks to do that no
what's gonna use such a system but it
turns out that unlike that sort of
historically the the image image
recognition neural network experiments
have focused largely on corpora of
static images you train on this set of
images you test on that set of images
but video is a different beast video is
a really different beast and in video
the premise is that image two is not
really all that different from image one
and guess what
getting a neural net or even sort of
classic signal processing to say oh you
clicked in this area well I'm gonna
segment that from the background over
the span of a couple of images or I'm
gonna do something really simple like
pixel tracking or image flow optical
flow based on the movement of the camera
and what I can do then is frame number
two can become another training example
for my neural net without the operator
actually clicking right and it turns out
that that works really really well okay
click once and then do some basic object
segments a foreground background
segmentation and an object tracking and
the the device itself that's learning
can take image - image 3 image 4 image 5
image 6 where Andy's moving relative to
the background as training images and
the fact that he's moving means that
they're actually really pretty good
training images it learns which pixels
are constantly associated with him and
which ones aren't
okay that's the clickbait project I'll
live this name clickbait click based
accelerated incremental training
clickbait so we did exactly that we
built a system that uses object tracking
and has a simple user interface for
interpreting clicks from a user
apologize for the spacing thing here and
it will learn you will learn and track
an object actually very effectively with
with quite few examples and without
boring you we developed a metric called
incremental training benefit that lets
us identify and measure how much value
there is to each training event
okay and what we're after is lots of
training with few clicks right and we
using this incremental training benefit
trick we're able to demonstrate pretty
robustly that using using drone imagery
and other imagery you can use static
cameras as well we can get five to seven
times improvement meaning a neural net
that has the same recognition accuracy
with one fifth to one seventh the number
of click events okay that's pretty good
okay but that's not where the story ends
we then said you know in in a
search-and-rescue and a campus
surveillance whatever application there
will be multiple sensors we made that
point right most multiple sensors and
they are dissimilar but maybe they both
can learn and they can learn from each
other while they're individually
learning so we built a system again not
to belabor it I'll go into the I'm not
going to go into the details it starts
with the premise that we may have a
bunch of cameras in a smart city and a
bunch of our CMU traffic sensors and we
postulate that the camera has this
clickbait capability that if you give it
a trigger either from a human or
something else here's the image learn
from it it can look at as the as the as
the object drives through the frame it
can get multiple training events just
from that just from a trigger but the
trigger doesn't have to come from a
human so for instance let's imagine we
have some area where someone's not
supposed to be driving our little
pavement sensor here detects that a car
has just driven over that spot it
triggers the nearby camera and the
camera starts learning okay well okay
that's kind of obvious and that's not
hard but here's the interesting bit we
learned that if you if you go down this
if you go down this path I'm going to
skip some of these details I'll have
them in the slides if you're interested
our little traffic sensor uses a three
axis magnetometer and we spent a lot of
time looking at the traces that come
from this magnetometer as cars drove
cars of various sorts drive over them
and we learned a really interesting
thing and I could I could perform this
experiment with you I don't have the
slides here today but we could perform
this experiment where I show you 10
different magnetometer traces from 10
different vehicles and then I give you
an eleventh one from a vehicle that's in
the set that's driving at a different
speed and you'd be able to tell which
one it was
okay so it turns out that with a little
bit of neural network technology in the
device itself we can train it to
deconvolve a vehicle speed and a
vehicle's type okay by learning the
magnetic signature right you can
correlate and figure out things that you
wouldn't know just from the triggering
that you typically magnetic sensors in
this domain are used for triggering
we're using them for learning the the
signature of a vehicle okay now connect
those two together when we see the
vehicle drive over the sensor we have
now evidence of its magnetic signature
and its image but we don't know for sure
which one is which but we can correlate
them and the next time we see that pair
we reinforce that if we now see the
vehicle on a magnetic sensor that
doesn't have a camera nearby we can
match it with the image of the camera
that we learned because we learn to
match the signature of the camera with
the signature of the vehicle okay so
multi-sensory learning self
reinforcement actually works and then
the in this in this domain the the last
thing that I'll mentioned once you
figure out how to take the number of
clicks that it takes to train somebody
to train them and on and on the drone
neural network to recognize and track a
target down to almost nothing down to
maybe just a trigger that a human
doesn't initiate now the question is can
we further extend that by one time
clicking on the image of Andy that the
drone can see and having the drone do
what a four-year-old would do you take
your four-year-old granddaughter to the
zoo and you say that's a lion what is
she gonna do she's gonna stand there no
she's gonna run around a model in her
mind of what the animal looks like okay
can a drone do that well it turns out
that it can and what we did was we
created so the hypothesis is we're going
to create a system in the drone that not
only does object tracking and
segmentation to train a third neural net
to recognize and ER anti detector we're
going to have a fourth
neural network that's trained offline in
the principles of how to move in order
to learn so we created some synthetic
environments of objects that we want to
track and occluders this is a this is a
photo realistic and environment that's
capable of photo realistic simulation
with physics you'd bump into something
in you crash okay this is a tool that we
created called Viper the virtual image
processing environment for research
interesting thing here is we can train
drones in faster than real time it's
sort of like the matrix right no neo
goes into the matrix and and learns
kung-fu without actually having
experience that what we have sort of a
dojo like that for for training drones
so in this particular experiment we
present the drone in simulation with a
variety of physical situations right it
can move in three-dimensional space and
simulation so when we say what we're
really trying to do is to train you to
recognize a build a mental model if you
will of that purple block move around
and get an idea of what's going on and
as it moves it will learn to associate
different kinds of moves with goodness
and badness it learns to associate
occluders on the right and the left with
things that will block its view if it
moves in those directions okay without
being explicitly told so across many
virtual environments and many scenes we
score the neural network on how well it
learns we penalize it for asking
questions and we reward it for being
able to recognize after a training
sequence that it's done well and so you
know like any reinforcement learning you
know game of fide system it just plays
the game thousands of times and learns
how to move to maximize its ability to
learn and then we apply that in the real
world so we take that same neural net
that has learned to associate the object
of interest with potential occluders and
we put it in a drone and we let the
drone fly what happens well let's see so
it's a little bit jerky and it's in its
and it's maybe hard to hard to
understand from what's going on here but
here's a simulated world where the drone
is learning and being scored in
real-time with should it stand in place
and take
images so as to reinforce its knowledge
should it move left should it move right
should it move over the object and it
has developed over experience scores for
which moves produce the best learning we
turn it loose in the real environment
and guess what it does so this is my my
student are in tang was the one who was
the prime developer of this technology
that we call autonomous curiosity we
were down at Camp Roberts which is a
military base flying drones we can fly
there safely using the facilities that
we have it was a wonderful moment and I
wish I had it on video Irvin was flying
this drone and he launched it and got
the image of a car that he was trying to
train it in the in the view in the
viewfinder it was actually trying to
train a car that was on the other side
of this building here so the drones up
there and he you know manually launches
it for safety puts it in position and
then turns on autonomous curiosity and
the drone does this and does this and
that does this he said I designed it to
do that and it actually did he was so
amazed that it exhibited this notion of
curiosity and blocked objects or
something to be avoided and it should do
it quickly because we trained it one of
the metrics is time which is a proxy for
battery power in the drone right so it
lor during is no yeah yeah yeah exactly
exactly I have a granddaughter now so
I'm yeah that's a great way to
appreciate what learning is all about
anyway to make a long story short we
benchmarked that against a number of
different flight strategies sort of
random pick a left-right up-down
direction or always go left or a bit or
whatever and the the offline learner
consistently outperformed the random
strategies which I think lends credence
to the idea that this this notion of
curiosity can be taught it can be
captured in something that can been can
then be reused
okay I'm gonna skip this and the traffic
crowdsource traffic sensing we're doing
a project with the US Geological
survey were actually deploying some of
these ideas in the field
we're auction and and that's sort of a
theme for another day one thing I do
want to talk about before we close is a
lot of what we do I'm an experimentalist
by by nature and I force my drag my
students sometimes screaming and kicking
out to the field we'd go down to Camp
Roberts three or four times a year sorry
exactly exactly you've got to get dirt
under your fingernails in this domain
right so this is as I said is a domain
that really lends itself to
experimentation in terms of surfacing
the interesting art problems rather than
just doing cool demos so we created we
created an environment that lets us do
these experiments well all of our
experiments typically involve something
that moves like a drone lots of radios
reconfigurable to different protocols
and so on some cellular some not and
we're in a very austere environment
where there's no power there's no
nothing so we bought an old a hambulance
used to blow into LA it was read in its
original life it got repainted as white
weari fitted it with a 42 foot pneumatic
mast put in a rack full of equipment so
we've got a whole stack of
software-defined radios and some sort of
private local cloud servers as well as a
number of radios and a SATCOM unit that
let us connect to the internet from
wherever we're at it's this wonderful
and honorable power source right that's
it's got a diesel generator a gasoline
generator three big marine batteries an
inverter so we can really run off-grid
pretty substantive it's got a ton of air
conditioning in it it's it's wonderful
environment that's a jack on the side
that lets you plug into the it's a it
comes from boating right this is what
they call the thing that you plug into
when you bring your your yacht to
Nantucket Harbor you plug into Shore
power okay so that's our ambulance and
it's it's actually served us amazingly
well I was going to bring it today we
had some difficulty in finding parking
space for it and so on but you're all
invited
those are watching by video as well if
you're actually interested in sitting in
it Eugene has been in it and can attest
to the fact that it's pretty cool but
it's kind of a Swiss Army knife or radio
neural network in the field
internet-of-things sensing research and
we we make pretty heavy use of it okay
it's also a really great 11 thousand
pound counterweight for when we use it
for amateur radio that so this is a this
is a four element beam with a 32 foot
boom and a 36 foot span this are
pneumatic mast will hoist 150 pounds
that's a hundred pound antenna so we use
that for amateur radio field day
literally we we go from you know one
megahertz up to six gigahertz with with
this van it's really it's a fantastic
resource sorry not with that antenna
alright so now this antenna actually
this antenna will do is design for 10 15
and 20 meters this is a really cool
antenna
these are fiberglass poles and inside
them is beryllium copper tape sort of
like tape measure tape with motors and
as you change the frequency of the
transmitter the elements move in and out
to make a nearly perfect one to one
standing wave ratio massive wonderful
antenna but that's an again that's
another story the one thing I have to
show you and for the sake of of
copyright I couldn't include the images
that I wanted to this van in some
spiritual sense traces its roots back to
the SR I bread van anybody remember the
SR I bread van good you can see it at
the Computer History Museum it's under a
tarp there but I put these pictures in
for here for our image this is this is
Don Nielson who is one of the architects
of the bread van and this is Vint Cerf
also one of the architects of the early
internet and there's a picture that goes
along with this that for copyright
reasons I did not include in my slides
but nothing prevents me from bringing up
a web page here's the bread van and a
much younger vint cerf so knowing this
picture when Vint visited that's an old
friend when vin visited I had to have
him come and do a do a stand
he had to pose for a picture with with
the cross mobile van so just to
summarize I think the IOT brings some
really interesting new opportunities and
hard problems that call for a systems
approach we've talked about the power
programming Federation and timing as
interrelated problems we also mentioned
the idea that networking can't be
cellular and I didn't go into that in
depth but the primary reason is that
cellular imposes a very high energy tax
for protocol overhead we can have a
separate conversation about that LP when
networks are free of that they have some
other downsides to them but but device
centric networking is really the
difference between what we're doing and
and cellular attached devices this
domain is very very well it benefits
from the idea of study develop deploy
evaluate sort of lather rinse repeat and
that's that's what we're all about and
that's it
that's all I've got for you today